at this historic sausage kitchen called
the boost coha customers can dig into
their pot forced with sauerkraut on a
plate or in a roll called a reagan spoke
- locals have been coming here to the
old district of leg and spoke for
centuries to eat the delectable sausages
they're not interested in mainstream
fast food chains businesspeople lunch
has to go fast the food's great here I
was born here you know I've only been to
McDonald's once
Kumal we show up eat leave it's faster
than McDonald's fast food sounds are
terrible but when we want to eat
something quickly we come to see get eat
the boss she keeps me coming back no
it's just a tradition legacy Maya's
great grandparents took over the small
Tavern in 1806
and it's belonged to the family ever
since
but its story actually goes back much
further a stone bridge was built between
11:35 and 1146 it's not been proven
because there aren't any documents left
from that time but the sausage kitchen
was set up as a snack bar for the men
making the bridge such to City Britain
elevator is done sailors from the nearby
port also like to come to the tavern at
the time there were only simple stews on
the menu sausages were introduced about
200 years ago when FAL Maya's ancestors
took over the reigns the new generation
is unlikely to do anything drastic Mesa
woman hates my son thinks tradition is
very important and that's the most
important thing I taught him he's not
going to change the time-tested recipes
one bit a sausage is grilled for about
10 minutes as it always has been
it's not like maybe it's like fast food
because of the speed but we're very
clear and simple there are no additives
which goes against conventional fast
food well since I am beauty school
students I'm casting falls to a taste
let's keep the rolls are home made by a
local Baker and the sausages are also
handmade handmade at the in-house
butchers some three thousand today the
ingredients are very straightforward
salt and pepper bacon and pork this is a
concept Optus flesh it's a very tender
meat
this is that's the secret you know we're
not a secret but it's just our way of
making them we use the finest cuts but
it's the flashing the mustard is also
made according to an old secret recipe
yellow and brown mustard flour brown
sugar
brandy vinegar honey and a bit of water
are all mixed with fresh horseradish it
goes down well with the tourists very
good yeah it's surprisingly I didn't
used to eat mustard and very different
because you always have rice with our
food but this is this is really good the
most kugel is one of the Bavarian city's
main attractions
and for some Americans it tastes better
than fast food at home this is probably
healthier and much tastier yes are you
ready this place to Houston Texas relief
there okay there are new plans for the
for school go to open up across the
Atlantic as yet but those who want a
taste of Bavaria back home can bring
back will screw his sausages in a can
and crack open a bottle of beer it's
tradition after all